foreign
[Music]
do not go outside I've just seen a hawk
[Music]
I'm not the thing is I refuse to be
triggered because I'm not sure
that's actually facts
[Music]
[Laughter]
I refuse to be triggered because I'm not
sure and if I have an emotional reaction
to that tweet it's just I am
that means I think I am
that's funny I just seen a hawk just
seen a hawk
that man can carry stuff Hawks as if
they grab your shoulder like that it's a
wrap gone it's a wrap that will be the
ickiest of all eggs if you're with your
girl and get attacked by a bird of prey
even if you hold your rope yeah as soon
as if he gets a lock of your shoulder
and he just dragges you like even if
it's a slight skid on the floor she's
gone your girl's gone the thing is I
could never be a pastor buyer seeing
that because I need to find the CCTV
yeah I would have to find whichever
camera is pointing to that bro and I
have to find it yeah yeah a hawk could
never drapes me up by your shoulder yeah
yeah bro Hawks don't [ __ ] about
so if he if he's by mistake yeah if he's
drapes is a five foot three King yeah
he's gone he's gone
dropping him he's gone
I can never
I can never visit you in hospital with
broken legs the same time what happened
what happened a hawk picked me out of a
crowd and dropped to me picked me up and
dashed me oh oh walks that's a hawk so
yeah oh what I found the first girl says
why are you
[Music]
[Music]
ask me stupid questions my legs are
broken James I don't have time for jokes
[ __ ]
oh that's jokes how the [ __ ] is the
customer always right bro I'm the one
that trained to work here
that's jokes right
Rags bro I trained to work fam I was
watching videos
I was doing CPL online on my days off
frags I know where all the fire exits
are bro I was doing test after test
after test [ __ ] this and you want to
tell me Steve sitting on table 12 is
right yeah customers always right fine
I'm right yeah literally piss off
that's hilarious I hacked my boyfriend's
phone the whole day I've been fainting
and waking up
I'ma move on
bolt drivers will be asking should I
follow the map no follow your heart
please
I'ma move on
I want to tell my homie he can't rap so
bad for real but he always has a gun on
him
wow always has a gun on him raw I'ma
move on why I rewind the show then pick
my phone up I missed the same part again
oh I have done that many times and I'm
furious with myself
I'm furious with myself James
that's what I know the ADHD is kicking
in oh that's John it's kicking in next
one bro how the [ __ ] ain't we run out of
phone numbers
thank you my exact same face ah how have
we not ran out of phone numbers
I wonder if the judge is lay in bed at
night like hey let me start again sorry
I wonder if judges lay in bed like I
ain't even have to give him 40 years for
real
they must do
there must there there must be times
where they pass judgment and they come
back and just tell their wife what
happened and she's like are you sure the
wife yeah are you sure and he's like
[ __ ] [ __ ] maybe I didn't have to give
him that 20. four years you should have
done 10. he really we could have done
10. little misdemeanor yeah oh I took
the person yeah [ __ ] oh well it's done
now [ __ ] done now
I'm glad he doesn't have hoes but why
does he not have hoes am I fighting for
a spot nobody wants this is the whole
lead of the group argument all over
again
that's jokes
[ __ ] funny right every time I even
every time I even stand up my dog gets
excited as [ __ ] he understands that I'm
a [ __ ] that can make anything happen at
any given moment
[Music]
that's jokes
I ain't never heard a baby say goo goo
gaga who the [ __ ] made that literally
who did who made that literally who did
this might be one of the funniest things
I've ever read some girl went for a BBL
and a tummy tuck and they stole her
kidney
thank you
Is that real went for a BBL and tummy
tuck and they stole her kidney in fact
this is why these men need to stop
cutting Corners bro do them because do a
legit thing go to where you need to go
go to where you need to go go to [ __ ]
Uganda to get a BBL and a tummy tuck do
you know what I mean these men are
always trying to cut corners
I saw one yet the other day so she went
to the Dominican Republic to be fat no
that's like the third spot I know what
I've heard for teas it's really good
I've never heard for bbls I've heard for
titties
so I think the the ratings are literally
America
then turkey
then Dominican okay where's next
because we just keep cutting Corners
yeah yeah I don't like it can these keep
getting draped yeah yeah and then your
your essential organs are gone I Black
Market type thing oh wow
seeing your friends while they're at
work interacting with customers is so
funny like that isn't the real you
right sex Rags I used to hate my friends
come and see me at work it's a [ __ ]
hate Max
came back to get some came back to get
another sample in Costco and the woman
said you know you can buy it right bear
shame
black people's fear of Eastern European
of Eastern Europe is so funny my mum
cried what I told her I was going to
Croatia
[Laughter]
oh that's funny why didn't you tell me
you had a crazy baby daddy and a son
reply I'm shy LOL
[Laughter]
funny Once you stutter in a heated
argument it's game over and that's a
fact that is literally a fact that's I
could never stutter male female I've
done it before have you and it nearly
went to blows well you started I've
started
[Music]
[ __ ] [ __ ] shut up
get your [ __ ] words out you [ __ ] oh
my God shut your mouth yeah yeah people
repeat blood will be spilled yeah blood
will have to be you can't stutter [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ]
these two back to back are facts men
cuddle like they look they're about to
live inside you
under not a nap literally is the best
combination to ever exist there's
nothing better there's nothing about it
there's nothing better sometimes it gets
too exciting though because I I'm more
excited for the nap than I am for the
nuts sometimes yeah so it makes me not
even want to do the nut because I know I
have the exact energy it's like saying
for me it's like oh
you can have the best sleep of your life
but you have to do 100 meter sprint
first and he's like yeah but I want the
sleep yeah it means I definitely don't
want to do this
I just want to can we just get to the
nut yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you don't
want to do the work up that makes sense
that's jokes I don't care how many kids
we have I'm not buying a damn van
somebody's not going yeah right I've
always said I have too many we've just
got two cars yeah and that's just fast
we facts
this can't possibly be the same 9 p.m I
used to be getting ready to go out on a
night out for
facts I'm tired bro we used to head out
at midnight head out we used to head out
at midnight my eyes are hazy at 11 P.M
I'm just not built for it anymore bro
I'm just not built for it anymore and I
have at some point I have to just come
to terms with it facts facts but yeah
that was total effect all right that was
very good that was that was very very
very
[Music]